And in this question, there's no best answer.
I would say a very common one is sensor malfunction.
So you often get sensors when a malfunction, they give it a zero.
So, these zeros are often outliers.
We have them a lot in robotics.
Data entry errors are common when someone enters your data.
I'd say aliens are not common causes of outliers.
You might be able not to believe, but I won't check them, sorry.
About freak events, sometimes you get a situation that is very unlikely.
But that combination caused an extreme data point.
And these are outliers you want to pay attention to.
Those over here, you'd like to ignore, and those over here,
you'd like to pay attention to.
So in, in much of machine learning, we try to
ignore the outliers because they often really caused by sensor malfunction.
And when you over-fit them, you get really bad results.
But there are fields, where people pay attention to the outliers.
A common one would be fraud detection.
Which is a special kind of anomaly detection.
Where people really care about, is that something in the data that
makes the report look so different, they should pay special attention to it.
So, depending on your application, you might hate your outliers.
Or you might love them.